tim cavanaugh Dallas Morning News and
star of ESPN's around the horn
he's been at Cowboys camp for a little
less than two weeks now and gives us an
update on what kind of drama is it does
it feel like drama Tim it only feels
like drama in the morning when I turn on
the TV and see what all the national
shows which is the topic of the day they
have selected you know it's different
watching practice it looks like cowboy
practice and there's not a there's not a
scariness to it like oh how will this
end which is what I thought was really
funny about yesterday's big news that
Zeke will miss games if he doesn't get a
new deal well of course that's what a
holdout is he's on that's what you're
holding your services to get a new deal
the Cowboys have offered a new deal he
doesn't like it yet at some point he
will and he will play if he gains
absolutely nothing he doesn't move
closer to free agency or anything else
he has no leverage for missing games so
that was just a funny one yesterday so
it's more it's abusing but it is strange
that the Cowboys have kind of let it get
to this point but you start to look at
this situation they're not fining Zeke
for missing camp right they won't say
Jerry hasn't said Jerry has always said
the rules allow it that's something that
he doesn't like he thinks the next CBA
which he went to Chicago
two nights ago to meet to have a meeting
on should spell it out that these fines
are automatic not at a team's choice
like like they I guess the charges have
said they're finding Gordon 40,000 a day
right at least it sounds that way yes
the Cowboys have only said that they the
rules allow that and they don't have to
say so that tells me they're probably
not but you know that that's an odd part
of the situation they don't they don't
speak to that so we don't know your most
recent article did the market shift on
at zekiel elliott howl Avion Bell's deal
changed negotiations for the Cowboys
running back
what do you mean well I just find it
interesting I mean that's what that's
what Stephen Jones kind of revealed
yesterday because I had him on the radio
103 3 FM ESPN and we had we had him on
in the first question I asked I just
read his quote about Todd Girly's
contract from the combine last year
saying Zeke will get paid I guess it
starts with Gurley and we'll go from
there and I just read it to him and he
said you know yes I did say that but in
Latvia Adele signed and Le'Veon Bell is
as good a player's Gurley and all 32
teams could have gone after him and this
is what he got and he believes the
market changed you know his uh his
guaranteed buddies ten million dollars
less than Todd girlies so it's an
interesting argument because the only
reason these the only reason DAC is
about to get thirty million years
because all these quarterbacks of signed
Russell Wilson and Rogers and and wins
and it each time it boosts the top
salaries so it always works in the
players favor in this case it kind of
worked in the owners favor
if you look at it that way and I was
just writing about is it fair for the
Cowboys to view it that way we're
talking to Kim Tim cattle Sean Dallas
Morning News columnist and around the
horn contributor but I also look at this
situation and with Zeke Elliott who's
more important for the Cowboys Zeke or
Maury Cooper I wrote about that last
week it's a great I think that's a great
argument because everybody assumes the
first thing people say the whole team's
built around Zeke he's the most
important player well we've already seen
they can put Eddie back back there with
this offensive line darren mcfadden ran
for 1,100 yards in 11 games four years
ago three years ago Alfred Morris had a
better average per carry
when Zeke was suspended than Zeke did
that year now that doesn't mean they're
better they're not as good but they
could move the ball with any running
back to God back there we see often
c-couldn't move till
we got here the receivers were terrible
and that all seemed to change they were
three and four before you got here in
seven and two after he got here and he
opens up a lot of stuff so if I you know
I leaned toward the Cooper into that
argument it certainly he's going to be
here longer presumably he's a year older
than Zeke but he he could be playing
when he's 31 or two and most running
backs are not so if I have to pick I
lean toward Amari Cooper
how would you handicap this division I'm
bullish on the Cowboys if everybody's in
camp here but I've said all along this
offseason I still think the Eagles are a
little better I think the teams were
kind of even at the end of last year the
one thing we don't know is how much
losing a backup quarterback hurts it
hurts a lot but I think the Eagles are
played with a Super Bowl a real Super
Bowl hangover last year and I think they
did the right things in the offseason
and they're just a notch ahead of the
Cowboys but one zieks here and once
everything's going I think I think the
Saints may come down a little bit and
the Rams so that they might end up
playing the Cowboys and Eagles could end
up playing for the best to the NFC not
just the best of the NFC East that's
what I think
did you watch Hard Knocks last night I
did I did sir okay I don't know if
you've ever watched Hard Knocks and then
said oh I got a good idea of how good or
bad this team is going to be just based
off an episode III did that with the
Cleveland Browns with Hugh Jackson when
he was allowing this conversation to go
on this dialogue and then he had
editorial control and didn't take it out
and I went oh boy
that doesn't bode well can you glean
anything from the Raiders and what kind
of success they'll have this year based
off last night
I mean that's hard but I don't think
they're gonna be any good that would be
my first take and I'm still there's
something about dairy car that's missing
for me I don't know he may be okay I
just feel like he's he's playing the
role of a quarterback on TV I mean yeah
he's a guy who plays a quarterback on TV
but isn't really sure he can in real
life but don't you think Tonio Browns
feet are gonna bother it that's kind of
a crazy deal it feels like they're going
out of their way to prop up Derek Carr
they're just going out of the wood just
say nice things it's almost like the
Giants management and coaching staff
pumping up Daniel Jones like you know
boy he's really good you know all these
things where you're going waiter yeah
why are they pumping these guys up so
much I understand maybe a rookie draft
pick at quarterback but Derek Carr that
surprised me a little bit it felt like
it was hey we got to say some nice
things about this guy man yeah it's
almost like they were instructed to and
and he's been around for five years we
kind of know who he is and our Gruden's
trying to reinvent him at least Lee gets
another quarterback but that's that's
shaky of usually the guy that they
portray in the first episode doesn't get
cut till the fourth or fifth the first
night didn't go well for mr. Ollie
few but it did lot of Drude in the
speech at the beginning that was a hell
of a speech yeah all right well keep the
drama down there let us know if
something really interesting happens
with the cowboy I know it has to be
difficult because like today do you know
what you're gonna write about today how
does that work with the Dallas Morning
News when they get this missive from you
that says I got nothing for you today
you know I have the kind of power
Wow it's not this is not a good day for
me tomorrow maybe why don't you write
about the National
a reaction to the Cowboys you know
that's not bad because I kind of hint at
it in a couple of columns maybe just put
it all together just put some names out
there just you know use this interview
as those million is my second appearance
on the Dan Patrick show subtle thing to
hear that's kind of maybe third I mean
if you want to call me out because I'm
I'm desperate for content I mean you're
right yes Tim you write a column I do a
three-hour movie every day you don't
that much you know it's once upon a time
and wherever you are and around the horn
is like twenty two minutes at content
and you're only on four you know about
four minutes for four at best yeah well
he talks all the sound overs I've got a
voice at three I think the winner gets
to talk to three minutes total well
woody no what do you paid stocks for
more than woody runs over what he runs a
little low woody should be on a word
count or he loses points all right all
right
because I'll bring back J Mariotti if I
have to that would be you know I'm gonna
point there I think that would be fun to
see but pay that way all right well keep
the drama down and let us know there's
some real names no no don't call me just
text me I know our relationship is not
based off of phone calls it's based off
text message mostly texts and photos
yeah photos photos from you
well I send you the one yeah I was
hooked up to an IV yeah I hooked up to
an IV the ones you send me are different
yes I behave alright that's Tim Keller
Shaw Dallas Morning News for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]